the work is done
[Music]
i won
I'm about to do
you can enjoy
[Music]
very very much
- gets on sale now how's it going
everybody it's Warren and last night
Marvel came out with a brand new
Avengers in game TV spot it's a TV spot
that came out on actual television and
not online and it has a ton of new
footage in it before we dive into the
breakdown if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe I just started a new
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway as well as
some Avengers in-game art if you'd like
to enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so as I
mentioned we saw some new footage but we
also got a lot of new dialogue from
Thanos as well the footage starts off
with feyo saying the work is done i won
of course he is referring to the snap
and the Avengers attempt to try and stop
him as we hear that oh say that he won
we see Captain Marvel Steve Rogers and
rody looking at the missing persons list
this is most likely right after Captain
Marvel arrives to the Avengers facility
and the remaining Avengers are
explaining to her what has happened and
as they explained to her what happened
and everybody they lost they show her
that Nick Fury was victim to the snap as
well notice on the screen we see some
new faces that haven't appeared on the
screen before we see Falcon The Scarlet
Witch and the wasp we then get a brand
new shot of Tony Stark who is still
stranded on the benatar at this point
although we know that Tony Stark and
nebula make it back to earth it is still
unclear whether they get there
themselves or they are rescued somehow
in this scene it appears as if Tony
could be seeing somebody come to rescue
him
it looks like he's kind of covering his
eyes from some sort of light so it could
be Captain Marvel or perhaps it could be
Ned of alyre if he arrived on net of a
lair and Eitri was alive he could
explain to him that he knows Thor and
that he also stood in fought against
Thanos and Eitri could help repair the
ship to get him home there's also been a
lot of speculation that Tony will
actually get himself out of this mess
much like he did in all of the other
Iron Man movies specifically referring
back to the original Iron Man when he's
stuck in the desert and decides not to
give up but to get himself out of the
mess in the scene he could be coming to
some sort of inspiration which could
lead to him getting himself out of the
mess and back to earth we then get a
shot of rocket and war machine in battle
falling this appears to be the same
scene that we saw them in where rocket
is standing on war machine shoulder in
the previous trailers if you look in the
background very quickly you can see a
blue black
which appears to be what has knocked
them down this could be at the Avengers
facility if Thanos comes to earth and
attacks the Avengers or this could be
when the Avengers actually go to Thanos
to fight him and then we hear fan o say
what I'm about to do I'm gonna enjoy it
very very much this is most likely
dialogue from the first part of the
movie where the Avengers go to fan us
and try to fight him most likely from
the special look that we saw yesterday
where Thanos has all of his armor on and
his double bladed sword so you can tell
that Fanus has some resentment towards
the Avengers and he's not going to let
them get in the way of undoing his
destiny so that's it for the new TV spot
it does seem like in the very beginning
of the movie there will be some sort of
battle between the Avengers and Thanos
so let me know what you think about this
brand new TV spot with new footage and
let me know do you think the Avengers
will go fight Thanos or do you think
they else is going to go to the Avengers
facility and attack it we have seen
scenes with the Avengers flying off but
these trailers are meant to mislead us
so we never really know so let me know
what you think in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe comment down below and like
the video so you can enter the giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers endgame and Marvel
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]